[Music]
okay guys be honest is this guy right
here officially get the coolest dad in
the world card yeah okay most memorable
costumes that you guys have ever worn
you're included in this definitely the
purge I liked when I was a bunny the
other year yeah as these two grow up are
you scared I'm so close to them and I
spend so much time to them with with
them I'm guiding them the whole way so
I'm not I'm not worried knock on wood
but yeah I mean that's your job as a
parent while you're you know alive and
healthy is to spend as much time as you
can with them so that's what I'm doing
and having a great time while I'm doing
it I know that you are getting ready to
release your first single is that right
yeah I'm working on it album my dad
helps with it and John Feldmann John
Feldmann to produce your record yeah
what about you or you bet even to music
as well yeah I am
so I'm the genre I'm going for it's kind
of like cingi rap kind of and rap yeah I
can they were raised on they've been to
the Beatty Awards when I perform with
different artists like little Wayne and
Tyga so they've grown up around
everything from dirty punk rock clubs so
really nice award ceremonies like the
Grammys so they're season family
collaboration happening maybe one day
right I'll do a song one day you guys
have a favorite blink song I like bored
to death
we actually wrote that about you know as
we grow older there'll be a time when a
home will be such a lonely place because
these guys won't be there anymore and I
gotta ask you are you working on a
follow-up to California right now I am
finishing up my solo album my follow-up
to give the drummer some and I've been
producing a bunch of bands no blink
follow-up style I think it's a little
little rest time for blink for the rest
of the year we toured for six months
this year like almost straight with like
oh we got here and there so the rest of
the year the only thing we're doing is
the benefit for Chester at the Hollywood
Bowl and then we're chilling I can't
wait